uh Donald Trump is also now reacting not
yet to Nikki Haley saying she's running
um but reacting to Ron DeSantis and Ron
DeSantis doing better than Trump in some
recent polls and Trump throwing an
absolute and complete tantrum on his
platform truth social
Donald Trump reacting to a report that
he's obsessed with the santis and spends
time trying to come up with nicknames
for DeSantis including allegedly
meatball Ron I think that's because of
desantis's physical appearance although
I'm not totally sure Donald Trump
posting some triggered messages to truth
Central starting with quote all of the
fake news is reporting that I spend
large amounts of my time coming up with
a good nickname for Ron Des sanctimonius
who is obviously going to give the
presidential thing a shot they are all
100 wrong I don't even think about it a
very unimportant subject to me this is
the evidence that Trump is obsessed with
Ron DeSantis Trump's saying I never
think about Rhonda Santos or his
nicknames to me means he thinks about
Ron DeSantis absolutely all the time and
then weighing in about the polling some
of which really has Trump doing very
poorly compared to Ron DeSantis Trump
saying quote doing great in poll numbers
leading all Republicans by a lot also
leading Biden by a very wide margin
which means that our weaponized
Injustice Department local DA's and
attorney generals oh come on it's
Attorneys General
attorney generals Trump writes will step
up their illegal and unprecedented
attacks in order to disparage me with
false bull
and statements in the hope that I will
be damaged enough to allow a rhino or
Biden to quote slip through the cracks
but be careful the American people get
it and don't like what they are seeing
Maga so this is a very interesting time
for Trump
he knows that desantis's numbers are
very good for a guy who hasn't announced
anything but if he spends his time
attacking a guy who isn't even running
it looks very weak Trump wants to be
Alpha and his followers believe him to
be Alpha to some degree as funny as that
is
but Trump must realize if he does spend
a lot of time going after a guy who
isn't even actually running against
trump it is kind of pathetic it is
weakening it is disgusting and kind of
kind of lame in a way so he's going to
have to figure out what to do just as
interestingly is that if DeSantis is
going to run against Trump DeSantis has
to figure out when and how to attack
Donald Trump and I want to talk about
that next one of our sponsors is Helix
sleep I have been sleeping on a helix
mattress at home for years now I
couldn't be more happy with it I
recommend it to everybody the other day
even though she's not allowed in the big
bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then he'll elix will match you with
the mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you are supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 percent off plus two
free pillows what other mattress company
is going to give you 20 off go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is down
below